good morning believe nation today I'm
going to share my favorite rules for
success from the past month and I hope
you enjoy and as always if somebody's
has something that really really
resonates with you please leave in the
comments below for quotes around it so
other people can be inspired as well
enjoy as a compound in Mountain View
California internet billionaire Naveen
Jain is hatching a plan that could make
him the world's first trillionaire
get to see my friend so Devine the team
is working hard as it usually is of
course so we're gonna land on the moon
somewhere around here close to where the
Apollo spacecraft landed at the equator
how did you think that idea well its
first of all it's on the near side so
it's easily accessible from Earth it's
an area in the dark area are actually
regions of lava Plains so they're not
mountainous nor so long ago it was the
Soviet in America's superpowers that
were locked in a race to land on the
moon now it's Bob and Naveen who are
leading the competition to mine precious
metals from its surface are we still on
track to land on the moon by 2015 we're
still on track today initially we
thought the mission was going to cost us
about hundred million dollars do you
think we can bring the cost down to say
fifty to sixty million dollars yeah even
less you know I think the first mission
will be under 50 and subsequent missions
maybe under 40
when would we be able to tell your honey
that I want to take you to the moon ten
years ten years not only will it be a
honeymoon but you're taking my honey to
the moon and I think that'll be the
killer if you can do that that's a real
business if we can go to the moon for
fifty million dollars and the cost comes
double Kuni and we're able to bring back
the things worth five hundred billion
dollars I don't care what anybody says
that's a great business somebody is
gonna create a trillion dollar industry
in space and we sure hope it's a see
when you tell somebody what you're doing
and they don't think it's a crazy idea
then you thinking too small so when you
walk up to your party and people say
what do you do well I mind the moon well
that's that's crazy
well I'm thinking big all the time and
then you push through it like you push
through it because what's the
alternative you're gonna leave that idea
stuck in your head forever that sucks
the alternative is you go through life
and you had this great idea and nothing
came of it because you got tired and
yeah sometimes you don't go to the party
that all your friends are at because the
idea is calling to you in that moment
wait for it's a great example of that I
was on my way to my friend's birthday
party when that lyric showed up when
death doesn't discriminate showed up in
my head
idea came on the a down I started
writing it down in the train and lucky
Nita
of the a train break dancers are dancing
I have my headphones on I get out I the
whole chorus comes all at once I write
it down and I suddenly see the shape of
the whole song I was just like the
chorus is burr that's who he is I go
into my friends party I go hey what's
that man
happy birthday I got to go I get on the
L train and I write the rest of the song
on the way back home from the L to the a
back up
2:07 Street you have to do that
sometimes you have to say no to your
friends to say yes to your work because
what are gonna do like lose that idea
because you decided like have a drink
with your friends like it's not worth it
your friend will be there for something
which is really really important is
which I believed you have to chase your
dreams dreams do come true
I've changed one for the last 21 years
one one cup for India after 21 years so
dreams do come true it may take a bit
longer than some but but they do come
true
sometimes what happens that we push
ourselves but not enough because we try
and then we say we find excuses we say
that all enough I have tried it's not
happening and you give up and one extra
step success is waiting for you which
you sometimes don't end up taking so
always be prepared to push yourself so
don't let expertise
silence you work to find new solutions
to old problems think outside of the
parameters that restrict other people's
thoughts just because you're a novice on
the job just because you haven't faced
the same challenges just because you
haven't climbed the same cliffs doesn't
mean that you can't contribute to
solutions in very significant ways when
you're chided for your naivete and you
will be remind your critics that an
amateur built the art experts built the
Titanic number one you all can tell you
gotta love what you do and I love what I
do I love real estate my favorite part
about what I do that I'm so excited
every morning to wake up to is that time
when you get to pass the keys over to a
new buyer of a home and they actually
bought the home and you see the smile on
those people's faces okay
that's priceless you can forget about
all the other stuff forget about the
money when you see the smile on a
person's face it's the greatest job in
the world
think about it we help people achieve
the American Dream which is owning a
home
and we get to be part of that and if
you're part of that those people love
you forever the first year yeah was the
first year like I'm at McLaren I've got
the two-time world champion he just won
the championship 2006-2007 he's got
number one in his car I'm gonna be
number two because that's how it it goes
and I remember sitting you know testing
just studying studying studying I've got
to make sure that I somehow would have
match this guy I believe in myself that
I'm somewhere in in me there's the speed
to keep up better than beat this guy so
um I mean before the first race Ron said
in his office is like you know but you
know you gotta expect and don't be
surprised if you have a second behind
Fernando at the first race you don't
know what that did to me aside I was so
what did it do like it just boiled me
inside because he will see under that it
not undervalue me because he obviously
gave me the role but he he he was not
expecting me to be able to answer to his
special new guy and so he said do you
expect to be beaten yeah yeah and so um
your life had not been about expecting
to be beaten no no so I mean I trained
like crazy
I prepared he did be me and qualifying
and he did beat me in the first race but
I finished just behind him third and
after that I I think I beat him in the
next right no I didn't think didn't
maybe the third race I beat him and then
I beat him in the championship but the
only in my first year my rookie year the
last rocky movie before creed the final
scene was it your way of saying goodbye
to the character goodbye to that yeah
goodbye and everything combines the best
chapters of my life it but he's
professional life he really was then
along comes this young guy out of
Oakland I go what Ryan Coogler Ryan
Coogler when director Ryan Coogler first
met with Stallone he was untested as a
feature filmmaker but he had an
intensely personal idea for reviving the
rocky franchise
googlers father had fallen gravely ill a
few years earlier with Ryan by his side
there was only one thing the elder qu
when it's a watch the father is a very
soulful powerful man and now he's being
reduced to its relevance for himself but
oddly he watches rocky again in again
and again his son who loves his father
sitting right beside him but he's
watching his father disintegrate before
his very eyes the traumatic impact was
so imprinted on this young man
that he never got over it so he comes to
me because Hey look at this great idea
we're gonna you know revive rakia go how
and what he told me story says this is
insane wrong you're a young kid you
haven't done anything yet
but I appreciate the thought because
okay so your own and because that he
does a masterpiece for outstation when's
the Cannes Film Festival every studio
wants and what's he want to do
Creed then went now either this guy here
is just trying my patience or he's
reminds me of a guy I used to know 40
years ago yeah it was absolutely then I
realized this is not a movie for him
it's for his father
this is all about a love letter to his
father you know if you really dug down
deep and ask a real rocky fan why he
likes the movies it's usually because
they watched him with someone that they
love was so great about them is they're
so personal to people you know he was
associating with their family let's say
you're about to get out of high school
and you say to yourself as you said to
yourself you know what I don't think I'm
college material the fear sets in that
number one if you don't go off to
college then the world's going to pass
you by that's first of all yes secondly
it is if something's going to happen I
gotta make it happen quickly I can't
afford to spend four or five ten years
in an apprenticeship it yeah I think it
depends what you want in your life I
mean what I realized very young is that
I didn't want to live in fear all my
years in school I did live in fear that
if you got something wrong they would
beat you I mean literally so you were
kind of nervous and I was always scared
that I could have a job which I may not
be very good in and my boss could hate
me and if he hated me he could fire me
and I thought I couldn't live my life
like that so I kind of prepared myself
to be good at something where I wouldn't
have to have a boss and then I would
only have myself to answer to and then I
wouldn't live in fear any longer and
there are times in this job where you
get nervous or you lose your nerve but I
don't wake up every morning like I did
when I was going to school or wake up on
a Monday morning feeling sick because
I've got to go to school so I'm a great
believer of if you're not bright at
school and I wasn't clever at school you
can teach yourself something good
provide you you have a good mentor and
providing that your patient running your
own race the man's trusting yourself
even when others don't because guess
what there are a lot of people good
people people who love you who trust you
and who you love and trust who want the
best for you and you'll come to them
with some ideas about what you want to
do and how you want to do it and they're
gonna say that's crazy just like when I
left my first engineering job at Kraft
and was telling my grandfather I was
going back to business school and he
said that's a great paying job that's
crazy and when I finished Business
School and decided to join the
tumultuous world of Investment Banking
my friends and my family and it was
spoke up with concerns about my sanity
and when I left goldman sachs right
after we've gone public to set up a
private equity firm called vista my
mentors and colleagues at goldman sachs
thought i was crazy and to top it all
off when i told i'm going to start a
firm we're gonna focus on enterprise
software and not be diversified like all
other private equity firms i was gonna
hire a team of smart young talented
people who'd never done this before
everyone knew i was certifiable and i
did this of course in the spring of 2000
about two months before the entire tech
bubble crashed well all i can tell you
is i've never been mad at these folks in
fact i'm grateful for the advice and
their concern because in their caution I
found my courage in their doubts I found
my resolve
and in their warning warnings I found my
voice and chartered my own journey and
I'm proud of the Vista story we take
risks we do things differently and we
listen to our own voice we run our own
race and it has worked we are now
considered to be the number one private
equity firm on the planet and have been
so for the last decade here's the deal
you want to know why most people can
never get anywhere in life why most
people never live never experience never
build never do anything worthwhile and
life besides being average and and and
let me know an average broker you know
why because most people's egos are so
inflated and so fragile that they won't
allow people to see them be bad at
something okay let that sink in you've
never done something before you expect
yourself to be awesome at it you haven't
done the work you haven't put in the
time you haven't put in the study hours
you haven't had the experience but you
expect to be good and because you expect
to be good but you know you're not gonna
be good
you don't do anything explain that to me
okay you want to be somebody who
succeeds you want to be somebody who
builds something you want to be somebody
who people writes books about one day
you are gonna have to be okay with being
banished for a long time when I first
started in business I didn't even know
what the that was selling okay I
remember the first person coming in they
came in for a product that I didn't even
it was called sell tech by a company
called muscle tech they came in the dude
obviously didn't buy it it wasn't our
first sale he came and asked me about it
I don't even know what the [ __ ] it was
okay but I didn't care because I was
gonna figure it out alright and that's
the mentality you guys have to have you
have to be okay with looking like an
idiot for a long time and a lot of you
guys you'd rather be too cool for school
you'd rather be the cool kids at the
high school lunch table then then be the
person who actually goes out takes a
leap of faith
decides they're gonna try something new
and actually becomes an expert at it
over time guys you have to be okay not
being good all right every valuable
lesson that you're gonna come across in
your life is going to come from you
something up aka failing alright and it
you know I hate failing as much as the
next guy dude I pry hold the record for
the most broken for Nintendo controllers
on the face of the earth because I hate
losing and if I ever find the person
that ruins Elda they're gonna get a
knuckle sandwich because I could never
beat that game but that's the point okay
I hate to lose but the thing is is that
once you understand that every time you
lose is an opportunity for you to not
only learn that lesson but take it a
plus-one step ok listen to what I just
said a plus-one step past the lesson
you'll start to appreciate those lessons
you'll start to be okay with not being
good guys you don't want to be the guy
that we talked about on the podcast
who's 37 years old living in mom's
basement yelling at her for a hot pocket
okay you trolling people on the internet
you don't want to be that guy and if you
don't want to be that guy you're gonna
have to understand that losing is a part
of ultimately winning you're gonna lose
a lot more than you win and when you win
you're gonna you're gonna figure out how
to get better on top of it if you're a
true winner you know they don't
celebrate their wins true winners take
the win and they say how could I have
even gotten better how could I have ran
the score up how could I have won by
twice as many points so you never really
feel like you win and you have to be
okay with that okay there's not one
thing that I don't look at in my life
and say man how can I get better at that
how could I win at that how could I run
the score up on that that's how much I
love to win
but I look at every single loss I've
learned to look at every single loss as
an opportunity of how to win more and
that's what you need to do to you don't
look at it like hey everybody's gonna
point and laugh
and they might point laughs I could tell
you a list of mile long of people who
have told me Andy you still got that
little vitamin shoppe Andy what are you
trying to be Tony Robbins Andy you know
when you're gonna get a real job you
know those are the same two asking me
for jobs now all right you guys have to
understand that if you are willing to be
banished you will have the last laugh on
these same people that that we're
talking about there's a bunch of people
that will say yeah well I've a family so
you know it's a great idea for you to
just go out there and go crazy I have
people to support you need to listen
stop saying that
stop saying any of those things every
single person who has ever done anything
worthwhile or exceptional or difficult
or extraordinary anyone whether it's
great artists or authors or
mathematicians or whatever the it is
everyone encounters difficulties there
is no easy road it does not exist it is
impossible everyone has issues if you
have time to pursue a hobby if you have
time to do anything in your life you can
better yourself and here's one way you
never better yourself when you come up
with excuses for why other people are
successful and you're not that is
dangerous when you give yourself an
escape yeah well that's easy for you to
say you know you do trust me everybody
has a hard road I wanted to jump out of
windows several times during my young
life I wanted to jump in front of a
train just end it because it's too much
pressure not really but you know I'm
saying theoretically we all go through
hard times we all go through depression
we all do go through doubt and in
moments in your life where it's really
difficult and you're trying to figure
out what the [ __ ] your path is gonna be
it's hard ish but Stefan and I we're
talking about this before the podcast
starts that that is what makes you a
person and those difficult moments are
what build your character show me a
great man who's the son of a great man
that's what we're saying these kids that
are born billionaires your
you're you're never going to be a
self-made person you have a backup trust
for your backup trust for your trust and
your demand well in third grade
this kid was always teasing me I won't
mention his name but he was always
teasing me calling me you [ __ ] you
black [ __ ] it's just every single day
this is way way back when so so one day
I said I'm gonna get him he was
considered the fastest runner in Central
Falls and I said I'm gonna beat your
butt I'm gonna race you at recess you're
not the fastest running Central Falls
I'm the fastest runner in Central Falls
I probably flipped him the finger you
know I was I was a vulgar kid too you
know I could give it as much as I got it
so at recess we decided to race and the
whole school was involved everybody in
the school heard about it and all the
boys and some of the girls were on his
side just kind of just screaming for him
and I had my three or four friends on my
side and we lived in such abject poverty
I remember that my we wouldn't keep up
the date with the shoes so my shoes were
maybe a size too small and it was the
dead of winter and I could never I
couldn't walk in the shoes I'd have to
stop every two steps take the shoes off
then put the shoes kind of back on and
walk again they hurt my feet so bad and
then my socks were so torn the only top
part of my socks were left so I said how
am I gonna race him at recess but these
shoes so I said I'm gonna take my shoes
off take my socks off I'm gonna take my
shoes off in the dead of winter in the
concrete and I raced him and I beat him
and I thought to myself it's only been
recently that thought to myself that
everybody was cheering and cheering and
he was saying you didn't beat me it was
a tie you didn't beat me
I said yes I did yes
did and then I got in trouble with the
teachers for having my shoes off and um
but nobody noticed that I didn't have
any shoes on and that's it's a metaphor
for life because nobody knows that when
you come to the race you don't come with
the same set of tools as everyone else
that even when you come into the race
with a deficit you still have to run the
same race and that's the metaphor I use
for my career you know that you you
can't be perceived even as the black
actress who doesn't get the same kind of
roles as the white actress you got to
run the same race you got to give the
same quality performances you've got to
have the same standard of excellence
even though people know that you're
coming to the race in a deficit that's
just what life is about you know my name
is Alex Parrish protecting our country
had always been my dream
Quantico was my first audition I knew I
had to go in to this room
and read these lines in front of all
these people but I was so nervous before
I went in so I went to the bathroom I
remember before I went in I looked in
the mirror and it's so stupid in place I
talked to myself and I said what's wrong
with you you've played the most
difficult characters in in in the most
complicated movies it tops my hair a
little bit felt great and walked her
did my bit and got the job the elephant
man has been a huge success
smashing attendance records and winning
Cooper excellent reviews from Broadway's
toughest critics for a role that's been
part of his consciousness for decades at
age 12 he decided he wanted to be an
actor after watching the movie version
it tells the story of John Merrick a
horribly deformed British man with a
saintly soul who was rescued from a 19th
century freak show and given sanctuary
at a London hospital twenty-eight years
later Cooper has produced cast and
arranged the financing for the current
Broadway production you play John
Merrick yeah without any makeup without
any prosthesis
mhmmm just you Bradley Cooper yeah and
you have to convince the audience that
you're him yeah how do you do that by
believing I'm him that's how I do it if
I'm acting like I'm in or I don't quite
make that leap of faith there's
absolutely no way you're gonna believe
it I had to do a tremendous amount of
work to get to a place where I do
believe I him part of the work was 20
years of research and part of it a
performance unlike he's ever given the
transformation from Cooper to merit is
shared by the audience in one of the
early scenes as the doctor is speaking
to the pathological society which
actually is the audience of the play and
you see an actual photograph of Joseph
Merritt he is then describing to all of
his afflictions from the upper jaw there
projected another massive bone and then
I then interpret each one in a physical
manner
the right hand was large and clumsy a
fin or paddle rather than a hand almost
mimicry almost like a mime you had a
further burden to his struggle the
wretched man when a boy developed hip
disease which left him permanently lame
so that he could only walk the stick and
once he's finished with that
presentation
I'm fully physically transformed but the
soul hasn't been injected yet
he brings the cane over steps away and
then says please and that's the first
time you hear America alive that is the
moment where the transformation occurs
and if I don't make that leap at that
moment the rest of the play is not gonna
work we shouldn't try to get everything
now you know I rented college I spent
eight years in universities I have three
bachelor's degrees and master's degree
five doctoral degrees bestowed upon me
upon by many different universities and
many of my friends are in a school in
Maine I school the United States jobs I
went to college you know they started
making money early I divided my money
maybe in the five years and now they
make in a year I probably make it an
hour so you know we need to be more
focused on developing ourselves rather
than trying to grab money now focus on
self improvement self expansion rather
than trying to get your pocket to expand
because you the more profit will you
make yourself the more value you attract
you not pay for how hard you work you
pay for which you are worth to the
organization and add more intellectual
development you
the most spiritual but you have the more
psychological developer emotional
stability you become more vulnerable to
the world and let me say this family
if you become valuable to the world the
world will pay you to be yourself just
once so it's important for you to become
a person of value not to seek value in
things I get paid for what I know about
what I do and I think this is what we
need to perceive as being most valuable
dealer they actually call in Internet
they call it capital you know
international capitalism is really a
tamale and so I want to encourage our
young people to focus on on discovering
the purpose for your life why God
created you and then the soneul gives
and then refine them develop them
practice them and then even begin to
serve them freely to your community
they don't yourself and in a short time
you discover that people will pursue you
because when you develop your fruit and
you maximize your full of your gift and
in life just like a tree trees never
bring their fruit to you in your sibling
manifesto you in fact you are attracted
to the tree so when you don't get some
refine your gifts you don't need to look
for followers they'll find you that's
right leadership is not about finding
followers it's about followers being
attracted to what you have and this is
true commodity the greatest compliment I
think I've ever gotten better than Oscar
better than Grammy etc was towards the
end of the last Dark Knight Rises you
know working with stars percussionists
that we've just sampled these guys have
played on everything they're the other
guys you know there's and there's
nothing they haven't played so my great
ambition was always been to go and do
just one thing where they go wow I
haven't done that before I actually
figured something I've noticed I'm not
gonna go into the details but you know
number one I got the compliment of
crying wow we've never done this before
and it sounds really good
well you're certainly bucking the odds I
mean they always say you can't have it
all at the same time I do believe that
you can have it all you can have
everything that you want you know if you
want it and you want to work for it you
can have it most people only pay
attention to the final product of a
successful entrepreneur they say things
like I can never be like them or they
got lucky
what most don't see is what they've
overcome
all the struggles the daily rejections
the heartaches the betrayals the rumors
the criticism the empty bank account and
all those lonely nights while trying to
make their vision a reality
you see the only difference between the
one who quits and the one who doesn't is
that they showed up every day
they worked hard every day they hustled
every day
they learn from a proven mentor every
day they improve every day
they get all this even though they felt
like quitting every day and eventually
they became who they are today
[Music]
so thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know your
thoughts I love to know one what was
your favorite clip and why what did you
learn most from this video and also do
you want this series to continue this is
the second time that we've done it and
I'm curious to get your feedback so you
may not have seen all of the videos
because I know we throw up a lot of
content so there's a compilation of all
the rules that I resonate it with the
most and so let me know should this
series continue or not give me some
feedback leaving the comments below I
really appreciate your thoughts and
finally I wanted to give a quick shout
out to Jonathan ballgame Jonathan thank
you so much for picking up a cup of my
book and sending that awesome tweet I
really really really appreciate you and
your support so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
[Music]